حضرت حركات حماس الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
مغبه ارتكاب اي حماقه في المسجد الاقصى
خصوصا خلال الاقتحامات المزمعه خلال
الاعياد اليهوديه منتصف الشهر الجاري
واكدت الحركه خلال وقفه جماهريه في مدينه
غزه لدعم اهالي القدس والضفه الغربيه
اكدتناها لن تسمح للاحتلال بالاستفراد
بمدينه القدس والمسجد الاقصى ودعت حماس
اهالي القدس والضفه للرباط ومواجهه مخططات
الاحتلال واكدتنا تهديدات الاحتلال بتنفيذ
اختيالات بحق قاده المقاومه الفلسطينيه لن
تخيفها
نحضر الاحتلال الصهيوني من مغبه ارتكاب اي
حماقه بحق المسجد الاقصى او قدسينا
واقصانا وابنائي شعبنا الفلسطيني
لان الرده سيكون
بالمقاومه لهذا الاحتلال الصهيوني اننا
ندعو اهلنا في القدس والضفاء و 48 الى شد
الرحال الى المسجد الاقصى والرباط فيه
افشالا للمخططات الصهيونيه التي تهدف الى
التقسيم الزماني والمكان للعباده